it's been two years since we last saw
the second deadpool movie but for
hardcore fans the wait to see your
favorite mercury for mouth is finally
over
what's up everybody zaki here from geek
culture and this is an unboxing and
exclusive first look at the hasbro's
marvel legends premium interactive
deadpool hit
you know what time it is roll the thing
[Music]
he goes by a slew of aliases
the regenerate degenerate
the milk with a mouth
the hit trip
this is the one to one scale of deadpool
but
before we get into deadpool's head
let's move on to the packaging looking
at the package design it is very
unconventional made to resemble a badly
used food box from the fictional subbies
fish tacos restaurant
the box comes decked out with a spot uv
printing to recreate torn up tapes dirt
and smudges all over the box
the printing is such that you can
actually feel the tape and the embossing
on the box itself it also has what looks
like red pieces of paper taped all over
the box with accompanying doodles by the
man himself
which will give you more of an idea on
deadpool's character
it's also good to note that the box
spots an 18 and up each morning so this
is definitely not a toy for your little
youngins to play around with as we all
know deadpool really loves his tacos
and i do too
and there's no better way for him to be
packaged than his own meal out of the
box deadpool's hit does kind of feel a
little hefty the overall feel of the hit
and its base is made out of durable
plastic at the bottom of the base what
you will find is the bluetooth pairing
button a toggle on and off switch
as well as the battery compartment
to power up the merc all you need is a
phillips head
screwdriver take out the two screws and
insert
four c size batteries
put it all back together switch it on
and boom
but before we continue if you like what
you're watching do consider hitting that
subscribe button and smash that
notification bell icon so you can stay
updated in our latest geeky news and
tidbits
give us a thumbs up so that other geeks
can have a chance to watch this video
and now for a quick commercial break
are you tired of finding your one true
love
can't find the person you meant to be
with from the jerks that brought you the
marvel legends series we bring you the
world's worst alarm clock
this super extra unnecessary head is
packed with 600 plus lines to provide
your lowly soul some
companionship interactive funny and
witty this is the best dance you'll ever
find
his head moves his eyes moves and his
mouth yeah well
you get the point
shake him hang him upside down
snap the [ __ ] out of him
cuddle with him
bring him to the bath uh
room
disclaimer battery is not included
please don't double hit in the water or
attempt to feed any type of liquids into
it please know that we're unlivable for
any harm caused by playing with the hit
be an attribution shot choking or
offending your parents this device
complies with part 15 of the fcc rules
please note that this head isn't the
real ryan reynolds and now back to the
show
so
this deadpool hit features lifelike
movements
live like live like movements yeah with
every twitch of his facial muscles
accounted for his flexible neck pivots
around so you kinda know he's watching
you and being the sensitive guy he is
deadpool can actually sense movement
light and even sound and what i find is
a really cool feature is his very
expressive eyebrows if you fill him up
you'll discover that deadpool's head is
dressed in an amazing spandex-like
material
oh god so good
and the stitching is surprisingly well
done with no loose threads at all
it's a pity that the mask is not
removable though so be extra careful not
to leave any stains
not that kind of stains are sick
plus the material is kind of a dust
magnet around the eyes
so you can expect a little bit of
dusting now and then it will also be
cool if you know deadpool's mask can
kind of lift halfway so you can kind of
see his [ __ ] up face
it's ugly
yes
out of the box you'll get an instruction
manual and of course do not throw this
away
which you can actually turn into an
origami hat
thumbs up hasbro recycling
and of course as you go along deadpool's
lines you'll find many are pure absolute
gold from dissing on the x-men to
delving into deadpool's metaverse
deadpool shares a dream about waking up
in a factory full of other disembodied
deadpool hits
i mean this is some next level
meta this might be disappointing for
some but deadpool's swears and cusses
are censored right out of the box
so
it might seem like deadpool isn't
deadpool without all his foul mouth
cussing
and i believe we can all agree that his
antics and humor more than makes up for
that loss so with all that said let's
mess around with deadpool's hit and see
what he has to say
all right
so
toggle on
[Music]
hey
i feel a little light-headed
oh no it's the body definitely the
missing body
okay that's
[Music]
oh
cool
uh i'm i'm sad that's unusual
but how do you think that shapes you as
a person
it makes me even sadder
tell me
is there anything missing in your life
love
[Music]
then what makes you think that that's
the case
because i can't find
love you're making good progress bob
i'll let your parole officer know
i'm not bob
canada great country or the greatest
country so as you can see deadpool is
sound reacting but it's not voice
activated per se so
deadpool doesn't respond to your cues
and queries
so that's one thing to know
i was busy thinking about ponies aren't
they just the cutest yeah all right and
let's try and pull them upside down
[Music]
[Music]
so that's all we have for today we hope
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
like comment share and subscribe so that
other geeks can have a chance to watch
this video and don't forget to smash
that notification bell icon so you can
stay updated to the latest geeky news
and tidbits
until then this is zeki
[Music]
you